I think just that one poem wouldn't do
it right we would need more than one
poem and if everyone could no one poem
everyone could know 25 poems it's not
that much harder especially if you start
when you're a child so I think there's
something beautiful about about the idea
you know I'm thinking of Adrienne Rich
again the dream of a common language
that's the title of one of her books and
poems and and a concept that I quite
like which is not about a flattening of
difference at all but it is about
thinking what length how do we speak to
each other knowing that we're coming
from different experiences in different
and different places and how might you
and I read the same poem and love the
same poem but for completely different
reasons that's interesting